im deutschen gibt es viele positionen
die mit dem dativ gebildet werden
es gibt auch präpositionen die mit dem
akkusativ gebildet werden und es gibt
positionen die mit beiden fällen
gebildet werden
was man sich leicht merken kann ist dass
alle positionen die einen ort
beschreiben mit dem dativ gebildet
werden
das zeigen wir euch jetzt wir starten
mit dem neutrum das auto das auto wird
im dativ zu dem auto janus steht vor dem
auto janus steht neben dem auto janus
steht am auto janus steht an dem auto
janus steht beim auto jahres steht bei
dem auto
jannis steht hinter dem auto
janisch sitzt im auto
janus steht auf dem auto
janus schwebt über dem auto janus liegt
unter dem auto janus steht zwischen den
autos es geht es weiter mit dem dativ im
maskulin das ist der baum
genauso wie bei das wird der in dativ zu
dem janus steht vor dem baum janus steht
neben dem baum janus steht an dem baum
jannis steht am baum januar steht bei
dem baum
damit steht beim baum janus steht hinter
dem baum janus liegt unter dem baum
jannasch liegt unter dem baum
zum schluss zeigen wir euch noch einen
femininen substantiv nämlich die bank im
dax wird die bank der bank
januar steht vor der bank janas steht
neben der bank janus steht an der bank
januar steht bei der bank janosch steht
hinter der bank
janus die zwischen der bank und dem
fahrrad
janosch sitzt auf der bank
janus tasche liegt unter der bank janus
ist auf der bank von moskitos gebissen
worden
tschüss das war unsere episode super
easy german upa die präpositionen bis
zur nächsten woche
janosch hat jetzt feierabend
gleich muss er noch alles schneiden dann
würde er gerne bier trinken geht aber
nicht er macht die es jetzt könnt ihr
noch so zu treiben und ein patch allen
werden wenn ihr ein bachelor werde
bekommt ihr ganz diese tolle extra und
unterstützt unser projekt darüber freuen
wir uns sehr so wäre dass sie haben es
euch ganz deutlich den ganzen tag zu
sich freut